This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. For generations across nations and cultures, parents and teachers have read Aesop's Fable, The Ant and the Grasshopper. It teaches children the importance of hard work and delayed gratification. It was a beautiful summer and the Grasshopper wild away at the time dancing and frowicking with its friends.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。世世代代，跨越不同的国家和文化，父母和老师们都会给孩子读伊索寓言中的《蚂蚁和蚱蜢》。它教导孩子们勤奋工作和延迟满足的重要性。那是一个美好的夏天，蚱蜢整天跳舞、嬉戏，虚度光阴。
This is psychologist David Distanneau, while the ant went out to the fields and toiled to grow and to harvest food for the winter. Why don't you stop working so hard and come play the grasshopper asked? The ant replied, I can't. I have to collect food for the winter. You should too. Otherwise you won't have anything to eat when it gets cold. The grasshopper just laughed and kept playing.
这是心理学家大卫·德斯塔诺。当蚂蚁去田野里辛勤耕作，为冬天储备粮食时，蚱蜢问：“你为什么不停止工作，过来一起玩呢？”蚂蚁回答说：“我不能。我必须为冬天收集食物。你也应该这样做。否则，天冷的时候你就没东西吃了。”蚱蜢只是笑了笑，继续玩耍。
When winter came, the poor grasshopper had nothing to eat and starve. The ant, who had worked all summer, had had a wonderful winter snug in his den and had ample food to live on. Now, the story has a harsh moral to it. The aunt, who refuses to share, comes across as mean-spirited. But the underlying message of the story is one we all wrestle with. All of us have something of the aunt inside us, and all of us have the grasshopper too. Study for the test or play video games. Exercise regularly or relax on the couch. Save money for retirement or spend it on something you want right now.
冬天来了，可怜的蚱蜢没有东西吃，饿得半死。而整个夏天都在工作的蚂蚁，在洞穴里过着舒适的冬天，有充足的食物维持生活。现在，这个故事有一个严酷的寓意。拒绝分享的蚂蚁显得心胸狭隘。但故事背后隐藏的信息是我们每个人都在挣扎的。我们每个人的内心都有蚂蚁的一面，也都有蚱蜢的一面。是复习考试还是玩电子游戏？是坚持锻炼还是在沙发上放松？是为退休存钱还是把它花在现在想要的东西上？
This week on Hidden Brain, we explore the importance and limitations of self-control. And we examine how a habit that is with an easy reach can help us achieve our goals. That overlooked habit, the practice of gratitude. David Distanneau is a psychologist at Northeastern University. He studies how we can enlist emotions to become better people, better to others, better to ourselves. Some of David's ideas grow out of the story of the Ant and the Grasshopper, and also a psychological experiment conducted 50 years ago by Walter Michelle at Stanford University.
本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨自控力的重要性及其局限性。我们还将研究一种触手可及的习惯如何帮助我们实现目标。那个被忽视的习惯，就是感恩的练习。大卫·德斯塔诺是东北大学的心理学家。他研究我们如何利用情绪来成为更好的人，更好地对待他人，更好地对待自己。大卫的一些观点源于《蚂蚁和蚱蜢》的故事，也源于50年前斯坦福大学沃尔特·米歇尔进行的一项心理学实验。
It's an experiment you've probably heard of. It was called the Marshmallow Test. The way the test would work is Michelle or one of his research assistants would bring in a child and they'd sit them down at a table. What is that? They'd put down a marshmallow or other sweet in front of them and say, you can either eat this marshmallow now, or wait until we come back and you'll get to. And they left. And what they would do is wait and see.
这是一个你可能听说过的实验。它被称为“棉花糖实验”。实验的方式是，米歇尔或他的研究助理带一个孩子进来，让他们坐在桌子旁。那是什么？他们在孩子面前放下一块棉花糖或其他甜食，然后说：“你可以现在吃掉这块棉花糖，或者等我们回来，你就能得到两块。”然后他们就离开了。他们所做的就是等待和观察。
Where is Camba? If the child was able to engage in self-control. And there's been video since that time reproductions of this, and it's wonderful if you watch. You can see the kids peaking through their hands You can hear the gears in their minds turning to try and resist And I smelled the marshmallow. I thought I would eat it by It and what he found right is that over time the kids who were able to resist, to have the self-control, to not gobble the first marshmallow, had better academic and social outcomes in many domains.
坎巴在哪里？如果孩子能够进行自我控制。从那时起，就有关于这个实验的视频和重现，如果你观看的话，会觉得非常奇妙。你可以看到孩子们透过手指缝偷看，你可以听到他们大脑中为了抵制诱惑而飞速运转的声音。我闻了闻棉花糖。我想我可能会吃掉它。他发现的是，随着时间的推移，那些能够抵制诱惑、拥有自控力、没有立刻吃掉第一块棉花糖的孩子，在许多领域都有更好的学业和社会表现。
So there have been concerns that have been raised about the marshmallow test. Some have pointed out that the kids that Walter Michelle studied came from a very narrow and privileged slice of American society. But the central idea of the importance of self-control, we know that, not just from Aesop's fable, but from our lives. We know that it matters when it comes to doing well in school or learning to play a musical instrument
因此，人们对棉花糖实验提出了一些担忧。一些人指出，沃尔特·米歇尔研究的孩子来自美国社会中一个非常狭窄且享有特权的阶层。但关于自控力重要性的核心思想，我们不仅从伊索寓言中知道，也从我们的生活中知道。我们知道，这对于在学校取得好成绩或学习演奏乐器非常重要。
or learning to play a sport or saving for retirement, eating healthy, getting exercise. Doing well in all these domains comes down to the same question as Walter Mishal was asking these kids, can you do the difficult thing now in exchange for a reward that is down the road? Exactly. It's saving for retirement, it's eating and exercising. And true, there are some socioeconomic differences.
或者学习一项运动，或者为退休储蓄，健康饮食，坚持锻炼。在所有这些领域取得成功，归根结底都回到了沃尔特·米歇尔问那些孩子的问题：你现在能做困难的事情，以换取未来的奖励吗？没错。这就是为退休储蓄，这就是饮食和锻炼。诚然，确实存在一些社会经济差异。
So if you grew up in a culture where you weren't sure that the future was going to be a beneficial one, then why sacrifice for it. But in general, as you're saying, there is just ample evidence that sacrifice in the short term in many domains of life is required for future success. Giving in to temptation for immediate gratification often leads to problems. You ran a version of the marshmallow test with adults. You gave them a choice between pleasure now versus a bigger reward later.
所以，如果你成长在一个不确定未来是否会变好的文化中，那么为什么要为此做出牺牲呢？但总的来说，正如你所说，有充足的证据表明，在生活的许多领域，短期牺牲是未来成功所必需的。屈服于即时满足的诱惑往往会导致问题。你对成年人进行了一个版本的棉花糖实验。你让他们在现在的快乐和以后的更大奖励之间做出选择。
But you decided not to use marshmallows but something else. How did you run this experiment and what did you find in terms of people's ability to hold off on a reward until the later date? Yeah, that's true. Most adults don't like marshmallows, but all of us like cash. And so we ran an analog to the marshmallow test where we replaced marshmallows with money. And so the way the experiment worked is people would come in and we would have them answer a series of questions of the form. Would you rather have x dollars now or y dollars in z days?
但你决定不使用棉花糖，而是使用其他东西。你是如何进行这个实验的，在人们推迟奖励的能力方面，你发现了什么？是的，那是真的。大多数成年人不喜欢棉花糖，但我们所有人都喜欢现金。所以我们进行了棉花糖实验的模拟，用金钱代替了棉花糖。实验的运作方式是，人们进来，我们让他们回答一系列形式的问题：“你愿意现在得到X美元，还是在Z天后得到Y美元？”
Where y was always greater than x and z varied over days to weeks to months. And from that, we were able to extrapolate a sense of impatience or a lack of self-control. And what we found was the basic result was people were pretty impatient. People were willing, as an example, to accept $17 now and forego $100 in a year. So another way of saying this is Shankar is, I guarantee you $100 in a year, but would you be willing to give that up if I gave you $17 now? And I don't know about you, but given what the banks are paying, unless you need that $17
其中Y总是大于X，Z从几天到几周再到几个月不等。由此，我们能够推断出一种不耐烦感或缺乏自控力。我们发现的基本结果是，人们相当不耐烦。例如，人们愿意接受现在的17美元，而放弃一年后的100美元。所以，换句话说，尚卡尔，我保证一年后给你100美元，但如果我现在给你17美元，你愿意放弃那100美元吗？我不知道你怎么想，但考虑到银行的利息，除非你需要那17美元
to survive, giving up the opportunity to quintuple your money in a year is a pretty foolish financial investment. But that's what our subject said. So when we tell people to exercise self-control, to do the hard thing now and get the payoff later, we usually ask them to exercise willpower. You cite the children's television show Sesame Street and specifically the character Cookie Monster, who regularly has to confront temptations. We want to grab it, but to eat it, or me, no, in way. But now me know that self-control is something
来维持生计，否则放弃一年内让资金翻五倍的机会是一个非常愚蠢的财务投资。但这就是我们的受试者所说的。所以，当我们告诉人们要行使自控力，现在做困难的事情，以后得到回报时，我们通常要求他们行使意志力。你引用了儿童电视节目《芝麻街》，特别是经常面临诱惑的角色“饼干怪兽”。我们想抓住它，吃掉它，或者我，不，不行。但现在我知道自控力是某种
mean us, or me, but to grab it, or me, but me, way. We want it. Describe this model of self-control to me, David. What does it ask us to do? Who better to talk about self-control or teach it than the walking, talking, and yourself? Gok himself. In that season of Sesame Street, Cookie Monster basically was teaching the model that has been in existence and psychology for decades and in philosophy long before that, which was our emotions lead us to stray and
意味着我们，或者我，去抓住它，或者我，但我不行。我们想要它。大卫，向我描述这种自控力模型。它要求我们做什么？还有谁比那个走路、说话的你自己更适合谈论或教授自控力呢？高克本人。在《芝麻街》的那一季里，饼干怪兽基本上是在教授心理学界几十年来一直存在，且在哲学界更早之前就存在的模型，即我们的情绪引导我们误入歧途，而
the way to persevere toward your goal or to delay gratification or resist temptations is to either rely on your willpower to tell you why you shouldn't do this. And so we see Cookie Monster using willpower or to use kind of tricks like to a song. We can stand on straight. We can take these breaths. We can sell regularly. But unlike cooking monster, most of us kind of don't do very well at this.
坚持目标、延迟满足或抵制诱惑的方法，要么是依靠你的意志力来告诉自己为什么不应该这样做。所以我们看到饼干怪兽使用意志力，或者使用一些小技巧，比如唱歌。我们可以站直。我们可以深呼吸。我们可以定期销售。但与饼干怪兽不同，我们大多数人在这一点上做得并不好。
You know, if you look at the stats on average about 20% of the time, people are trying to resist a temptation. They give into it for things that are difficult and important. It it's even worse if you look at New Year's resolutions, 8% of them are kept to the years then, 25% of them are gone by mid-January. And so if this strategy of relying on kind of logic and willpower was the best that we had to offer, it's pretty poor because we're failing. Okay, we did long enough. I'm numb, numb, numb, numb, numb, numb, numb, numb, numb, numb, numb, numb, numb, numb, numb. Most of us think of self-control in the context of personal goals, things like health or exercise
你知道，如果你看统计数据，平均大约20%的时间里，人们试图抵制诱惑。对于困难和重要的事情，他们会屈服。如果你看新年决心，情况更糟，8%的人能坚持到年底，25%的人到一月中旬就放弃了。所以，如果这种依靠逻辑和意志力的策略是我们所能提供的最好的方法，那它真的很糟糕，因为我们失败了。好吧，我们做得够久了。我麻木了，麻木了……我们大多数人认为自控力是在个人目标的背景下，比如健康或锻炼。
David, but you also need self-control to be a good person to act with integrity. You once conducted an experiment that tested the relationship between self-control and people's willingness to act with integrity You asked volunteers to choose between a difficult task and an easy task using the equivalent of a coin flip Can you describe the experimental setup to me? Sure subjects would come in and we told them there were two tasks that needed to be done a long long and onerous one, or a shortened, fun one. And then we gave them the opportunity to flip a coin to decide what they were going to do. And if you ask people what should you do,
大卫，但你也需要自控力来做一个好人，以正直行事。你曾经进行过一项实验，测试了自控力与人们以正直行事意愿之间的关系。你要求志愿者使用类似抛硬币的方法在困难任务和简单任务之间做出选择。你能向我描述一下实验设置吗？当然，受试者会进来，我们告诉他们有两项任务需要完成：一项漫长而繁重的任务，或者一项简短、有趣的任务。然后我们给他们机会抛硬币来决定他们要做什么。如果你问人们应该做什么，
people will say, well, of course, you should follow what the coin says. That's the only time we get kind of unanimity in a psychological study that I've ever seen. Yet, the vast majority of people when they believe in their alone and no one can see what they're choosing, either don't flip the coin and just give themselves
人们会说，当然，你应该遵循硬币的结果。这是我在心理学研究中见过的唯一一次达成某种一致意见的情况。然而，绝大多数人在认为自己独处且没有人能看到他们的选择时，要么不抛硬币，直接给自己
the easy task or they flip the coin, get the wrong answer because of course, we have rigged the coin so that it comes up such that they should do the hard task, that's a virtual coin. And keep flipping it until it comes up with the answer they want. What were these two tasks, David, that what was the difficult task that people wanted to avoid? Sure. The difficult task was presented as a series of 45 minutes of long and
分配简单任务，要么抛了硬币，得到了错误的结果——因为当然，我们操纵了硬币，让它显示他们应该做困难的任务，那是一个虚拟硬币——然后不停地抛，直到它出现他们想要的答案。大卫，这两项任务是什么？人们想要避免的困难任务是什么？当然，困难任务被呈现为一系列45分钟的漫长而
onerous logic problems, so things that you might have to do in like the GRE or the SAT. And the short task was said about 10 minutes. It's a fun image hunt on computer screen. I see. And so you found, I think upwards of 90% of your volunteers succumbed to the temptation of cheating? We did. Yes, we did. And these were normal people just like you and me.
繁重的逻辑问题，就像你在GRE或SAT考试中可能遇到的那样。而简短的任务被说成大约10分钟。这是一个电脑屏幕上的趣味找图游戏。我明白了。所以你发现，我想有超过90%的志愿者屈服于作弊的诱惑？是的，我们发现了。而且这些人都是像你我一样的普通人。
But in those moments where we think we can get away with something people will, but the most interesting part about it was when we asked them later, how fairly that they act, most of them just created a story for why it was okay, for them to do that this time. Oh, I really didn't want to be late for something. My favorite story was, and I kid you not, they said to me, one person said to me, well, the guy who was sitting out in the hall who I thought was going to be coming next. He looked like an engineering major and I thought he would like the logic problem.
但在那些我们认为可以侥幸逃脱的时刻，人们会这样做。但最有趣的部分是，当我们后来问他们行事是否公平公正时，他们大多数人只是编造了一个故事，解释为什么他们这次这样做是可以的。哦，我真的不想因为什么事情而迟到。我最喜欢的故事是——我没开玩笑——他们对我说，有一个人对我说，好吧，坐在大厅里那个我以为接下来会进来的人。他看起来像个工程专业的学生，我想他会喜欢逻辑问题的。
Right? So, you know. But the tricky part about this right is if we're willing to rationalize away our need for self-control, that we're not going to try and exert willpower in the first place. We're ever going to say, I deserve to spend money on the new smartphone. I deserve the extra piece of chocolate cake. Movies and TV shows have explored the idea of why we give in to temptation.
对吧？所以，你知道。但棘手的部分在于，如果我们愿意为自己对自控力的需求找借口，那么我们一开始就不会尝试运用意志力。我们总是会说，我值得花钱买那部新智能手机。我值得多吃那块巧克力蛋糕。电影和电视节目探讨了我们为什么会屈服于诱惑的想法。
The cartoon character Homer Simpson is the personification of this idea. Oh! Donuts, is there anything they can't do? Dad, you're a hero. Homer Simpson knows he needs to resist junk food, but he just can't do it. David says this idea that our emotions often get the better of us. This is the way most of us understand why will power fails.
卡通人物荷马·辛普森就是这个想法的化身。哦！甜甜圈，有什么是它们做不到的吗？爸爸，你是英雄。荷马·辛普森知道他需要抵制垃圾食品，但他就是做不到。大卫说，这种认为我们的情绪经常战胜我们的想法，是我们大多数人理解意志力为何失败的方式。
There is this idea that's been around since the time of spinos or before, where people look at the passions, that their emotions as something that wants immediate gratification. And sure, we experience it that way at times. You know, we can feel desire or lust or anger, things that make us want to do things in the moment. And there's this idea that we have to rely on kind of our rational thought processes to kind of change our view of what we should value and to tamp
自斯宾诺莎时代或更早以来，就存在这样一种观点，人们将激情，即他们的情绪，视为想要即时满足的东西。当然，我们有时确实会有这种感觉。你知道，我们可以感受到欲望、色欲或愤怒，这些东西让我们在当下想要做某些事情。而且有一种观点认为，我们必须依靠我们的理性思维过程来改变我们对应该重视什么的看法，并压制
down those cravings. And that requires self-control to do the right thing. Now, there's been other work that shows that fighting your desires, fighting your temptations with willpower. It's not just difficult, but it's actually stressful, right? It is. I mean, if you think about it, your body is in a state of stress. Part of you is wanting to give into whatever the temptation is for short-term pleasure. And part of you is trying to overrule that sense of desire. And so when you're trying to come back in and exert executive control, which is a fancy word we psychologists use for trying to overrule kind of our more intuitive responses, your brain feels like, and I'm not saying this is what's going on in the circuitry, of course, but it feels like
那些渴望。而这需要自控力来做正确的事情。现在，还有其他研究表明，用意志力对抗你的欲望、对抗你的诱惑，不仅困难，而且实际上压力很大，对吧？确实。我的意思是，如果你仔细想想，你的身体处于一种压力状态。你的一部分想要屈服于任何短期快乐的诱惑。而你的一部分正在试图推翻那种欲望感。所以当你试图回来并运用执行控制——这是我们心理学家用来指试图推翻我们更直觉反应的一个花哨词汇——时，你的大脑感觉就像——我当然不是说这就是电路中发生的事情——但它感觉就像
you're in a battle. And that results in stress. There's great work by a psychologist Gregory Miller at Northwestern. He was trying to work with kids from disadvantaged backgrounds, showing them, teaching them executive control strategies. And over time, yes, those strategies worked, but the stress level that those children were and adolescents were under began to manifest itself physically. And so if you kind of expand that out, the upshot is, yes, if you're always trying to exert self control, you can achieve your goals, but your health is going to suffer. You're not going to be as round as long as you enjoy the fruits of that. You also cite a study by Christopher Boyce about people who in fact are very good at exercising willpower, but what happens to them when they fail? Do you remember that study, David?
你在战斗。这会导致压力。西北大学的心理学家格雷戈里·米勒做了出色的工作。他试图与来自弱势背景的孩子们合作，向他们展示、教导他们执行控制策略。随着时间的推移，是的，这些策略奏效了，但这些儿童和青少年所承受的压力水平开始在生理上表现出来。所以如果你把这个扩展开来，结论是，是的，如果你总是试图行使自控力，你可以实现你的目标，但你的健康会受到影响。你不会像享受那些成果一样长寿。你还引用了克里斯托弗·博伊斯的一项研究，关于那些实际上非常擅长行使意志力的人，但当他们失败时会发生什么？大卫，你还记得那项研究吗？
Yeah, so this was a study looking at the trait of conscientiousness, which is the ability to kind of put your nose to the grindstone and persevere in pursuing your goals. And people who do that, yes, they succeed, but when they do fail, and they do fail less because they're working really hard, but when they fail, what he shows is the hit to their well-being is 120% greater than the rest of us. And although the data doesn't show exactly why that is
是的，这是一项研究“尽责性”这一特质的研究，即那种能够埋头苦干并坚持追求目标的能力。那些这样做的人，是的，他们成功了，但当他们失败时——他们确实失败得更少，因为他们工作非常努力——但当他们失败时，他展示的是，这对他们幸福感的打击比我们其他人大120%。虽然数据并没有确切显示为什么会这样，
and that study, personally, I believe that one reason that is is because these individuals haven't been focused on cultivating the social relationships that are there to catch us when we fall on to make us more resilient. Psychologist David Distanneau argues that the model we have that will power is the key to self-control and that our emotions often undermine us. This model misses something crucial. Emotions might not be the enemy. In fact, some emotions can play a powerful role in generating self-control.
在那项研究中，我个人认为原因之一是，这些个体并没有专注于培养那些在我们跌倒时接住我们、让我们更有韧性的社会关系。心理学家大卫·德斯塔诺认为，我们认为意志力是自控力关键的模型，以及我们的情绪经常破坏我们的模型，忽略了一些至关重要的东西。情绪可能不是敌人。事实上，某些情绪可以在产生自控力方面发挥强大的作用。
How? That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Think back to the last time you made a resolution and failed. Maybe the resolution was to get your finances in order or to exercise more. Maybe it was to eat healthy. You even made a list of all the reasons you should order more salads. But those reasons failed you when you smelled French fries at the next table. Your emotions got the better of you. Many of us see our emotions as the enemy when it comes to carrying out our resolutions, but we often forget something. Emotions can also be enormously constructive and powerful.
如何实现？这就是我们回来后要讨论的内容。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。回想一下你上次制定决心却失败的时候。也许那个决心是理清财务状况或多锻炼。也许是健康饮食。你甚至列出了所有你应该多点沙拉的理由。但当你闻到隔壁桌的炸薯条时，这些理由就失效了。你的情绪战胜了你。我们许多人认为情绪是实现决心时的敌人，但我们经常忘记一件事。情绪也可以是非常具有建设性和力量的。
David, it might make sense to back up and see the big picture for a moment. Many of us think that something makes us angry, so we feel angry, something makes us sad, so we feel sad, something makes us angry, so we feel angry, something makes us sad, so we feel sad, something makes us happy, so we feel happy. We think emotions are about looking back at reacting to the past. You say there's something wrong with this picture. What is it? Yeah, emotions are not about the past. They are about the future.
大卫，退后一步，从大局来看可能是有意义的。我们许多人认为某事让我们生气，所以我们感到愤怒；某事让我们悲伤，所以我们感到悲伤；某事让我们快乐，所以我们感到快乐。我们认为情绪是关于回顾过去、对过去做出反应。你说这个画面有什么问题。是什么？是的，情绪不是关于过去的。它们是关于未来的。
And what I mean by that is if you even just think about the brain metabolically, what good it would it be to have a response that is only relevant to things that have happened before? The reason we have emotions are to help us decide what to do next. When you are feeling in emotion it's altering the computations your brain is making your predictions for the best course of action. Some years ago you started to explore an interesting idea. If emotions are a mechanism to help us navigate the future, not just an accounting system to tabulate the past, that might explain why some emotions seem to help us do difficult things.
我的意思是，如果你从代谢的角度思考大脑，拥有一个只与过去发生过的事情相关的反应有什么用呢？我们拥有情绪的原因是帮助我们决定下一步做什么。当你感受到一种情绪时，它正在改变你大脑正在进行的计算，改变你对最佳行动方案的预测。几年前，你开始探索一个有趣的想法。如果情绪是一种帮助我们导航未来的机制，而不仅仅是一个记录过去的会计系统，那可能解释了为什么有些情绪似乎能帮助我们做困难的事情。
You tell the story in your book of one of your students who would wake up early each morning to go rowing on the Columbia River in the Pacific Northwest. What did she tell you? Yeah, this was my student Lisa Williams, who's now a professor at the University of New South Wales in Australia. And she told me, you know, it was very difficult to wake up before the sun rises and to go out in the cold damp of the Pacific Northwest and to get on the Columbia River in row.
你在书中讲述了你的一名学生的故事，她每天清晨醒来去太平洋西北部的哥伦比亚河划船。她告诉了你什么？是的，这是我的学生丽莎·威廉姆斯，她现在是澳大利亚新南威尔士大学的教授。她告诉我，你知道，在太阳升起前醒来，去太平洋西北部寒冷潮湿的环境中，到哥伦比亚河上划船是非常困难的。
But she felt pride for being accepted on to the rowing team and pride for how well her team was doing and not wanting to let her team down. And so it was that sense of pride for the accomplishments they made each day and the anticipated pride for what was going to come next that helps her do these difficult things that helped her get up in at a morning when many of us might just want to roll over and hit the alarm for snooze. And it's because sometimes we do hard things because we think we should, but I think more often than not, we do hard things because we feel we should. Emotions are a huge source of motivation.
但她为能被划船队录取感到自豪，为她的团队表现出色感到自豪，并且不想让她的团队失望。所以，正是那种为每天取得的成就而感到的自豪，以及对接下来会发生什么的预期自豪，帮助她做了这些困难的事情，帮助她在我们许多人可能只想翻个身按下闹钟继续睡的时候起床。这是因为有时我们做困难的事情是因为我们认为我们应该这样做，但我认为更多时候，我们做困难的事情是因为我们觉得我们应该这样做。情绪是巨大的动力来源。
So, this is an example of how emotions can help us meet our resolutions rather than undermine our resolutions. So rather than see all emotions as the enemy of reaching our goals, you started to ask if some emotions could in fact help us reach our goals. In the case of the student, it was the pride she felt being part of the team and not pride at the level of arrogance or hubris, but taking delight in a job well done in teamwork.
所以，这是一个情绪如何帮助我们实现决心而不是破坏决心的例子。因此，与其将所有情绪视为实现目标的敌人，你开始询问某些情绪是否实际上可以帮助我们实现目标。在那个学生的案例中，是她作为团队一员感到的自豪，而不是傲慢或狂妄层面的自豪，而是从出色的工作和团队合作中获得快乐。
That's exactly right. So you decided to explore how emotions might shape self-control and long-term decision-making. You gave Adult Volunteers the grown-up version of the Marshmallow Test, the one that used money, but this time there was a twist. You measured differences between people in terms of how much they experienced the emotion of gratitude. Was there a correlation between gratitude and people's ability to delay gratification? There was. And what we found was when they were feeling grateful when they were making these decisions because they had just reflected on something that they were grateful
完全正确。所以你决定探索情绪如何塑造自控力和长期决策。你给成年志愿者做了成人版的棉花糖实验，就是那个使用金钱的实验，但这次有一个转折。你测量了人们在体验感恩情绪方面的差异。感恩与人们延迟满足的能力之间是否存在相关性？确实存在。我们发现，当他们在做这些决定时感到感恩——因为他们刚刚反思了他们感恩的事情——
for, it basically doubled their self-control. Suddenly, they weren't willing to give up $100 in a year for $17 now. It would take about $31 for them to do this. But the important thing was to show that it wasn't just that we were distracting them or wasn't anything about just feeling good. When people were feeling happy, we asked them to describe something that they thought was funny and amusing. They were the same as people who were neutral. It was $17.
这基本上使他们的自控力翻了一番。突然之间，他们不再愿意为了现在的17美元而放弃一年后的100美元。他们需要大约31美元才会这样做。但重要的是要证明，这不仅仅是因为我们分散了他们的注意力，或者不仅仅是因为感觉良好。当人们感到快乐时，我们让他们描述一些他们认为有趣和好笑的事情。他们的表现与中性的人一样。还是17美元。
And so what this tells us is that when you feel gratitude, it alters the computations your brain is making about how valuable a future goal is. I mean, what's interesting, of course, is you're not actually telling people anything about self-control here. You're not telling them, here's the right thing to do, exercise willpower, here's the rational thing to do. You're just asking them to reflect on something they felt grateful for, maybe someone in their life who was good to them or a colleague or a mentor who had helped them and this Indirectly seemed to change the way they thought about the present and thought about the future. That's exactly right I mean emotions set our expectations for how we should react in any given situation we're in and so simply by making people feel grateful
所以这告诉我们，当你感到感恩时，它会改变你大脑对未来目标价值的计算。我的意思是，有趣的是，你在这里并没有真正告诉人们关于自控力的任何事情。你没有告诉他们，“这是正确的事情，行使意志力，这是理性的做法。”你只是让他们反思他们感到感恩的事情，也许是生命中对他们好的人，或者是一个帮助过他们的同事或导师，而这间接地改变了他们看待现在和看待未来的方式。完全正确。我的意思是，情绪设定了我们在任何特定情况下应该如何反应的期望，所以仅仅通过让人们感到感恩，
It altered the way their brain assigned value as a function of time. Suddenly rewards that were delayed, that were further in the future, seemed more attractive than they normally would. Without them having to engage in any type of corrective strategy to kind of make themselves or will themselves to see the logic of that. Now you wanted a stronger test of the idea that there was a connection between gratitude and long-term thinking, and rather than simply have people remember a time when they felt grateful, you artificially induced them to feel grateful.
它就改变了他们大脑分配价值的方式，作为时间的函数。突然之间，那些延迟的、在更遥远未来的奖励，看起来比平时更有吸引力了。而不需要他们采取任何类型的纠正策略来强迫自己或用意志力去理解其中的逻辑。现在，你想要对感恩与长期思维之间存在联系的想法进行更强有力的测试，而不是简单地让人们回忆他们感到感恩的时刻，你人为地诱导他们感到感恩。
Now, that's not very easy to do in a lab, and you came up with a rather, I would say, cruel way to engineer gratitude. How did you do it, David? Well, the way it worked is you'd come to the lab and you would sit in front of a computer and you spent about 15, 20 minutes doing this god-awful task and it was designed to be god-awful and boring and hard. And right at the end, when the experimenter said they were going to come in and record your score that would have been put on the computer screen, we rigged the computer to look like it crashed. And so when it crashed, the subjects
现在，在实验室里做到这一点并不容易，你想到了一种，我会说，相当残酷的方法来设计感恩。大卫，你是怎么做到的？嗯，它的运作方式是，你来到实验室，坐在电脑前，花了大约15到20分钟做这个糟糕透顶的任务，它被设计得既糟糕又无聊且困难。就在最后，当实验者说他们要进来记录你的分数——这些分数本应显示在电脑屏幕上——我们操纵了电脑，让它看起来像是死机了。所以当它死机时，受试者
would be like, oh my goodness, oh, this is terrible. And the experimenter would come in and say, oh, this has happened once before. Let me go get the tech. You're going to have to do this all over. And of course, they were not happy. We also had in the room another person who was a Confederate, which means they were an actor working for the experimenters. But the participants thought they were just another person in the experiment. And this Confederate would get up and say, oh, I have to leave, I'm running late,
会说，“哦，天哪，哦，这太糟糕了。”实验者会进来，说，“哦，这种情况以前发生过一次。让我去叫技术人员。你得重做一遍。”当然，他们很不高兴。我们还在房间里安排了另一个人，是一个同谋，这意味着他们是为实验者工作的演员。但参与者以为他们只是实验中的另一个人。这个同谋会站起来说，“哦，我得走了，我快迟到了，
but this is really terrible. I'm pretty good with computers. Let me see if I can help you. And so she would start fudzing with the computer and she would hit a button so repetitiously that would start to countdown and then suddenly the computer would come back on. And 95% of our participants
但这真的很糟糕。我挺擅长电脑的。让我看看能不能帮你。”所以她会开始摆弄电脑，她会反复按一个按钮，开始倒计时，然后突然电脑又恢复正常了。我们95%的参与者
were so grateful to the United States Task Overgan, 5% of convinced they fixed it themselves somehow. But they were really, really, really grateful for this. And that's the way we kind of induce gratitude in real time. So when you induce gratitude in this manner, David, do you see that it changes people's ability to think about the future differently? Yeah, so what we find when we use this paradigm and we used it several times is it makes people more willing to Pay it forward that is it makes them more willing to what will have them leave the lab and go out and suddenly somebody Who's another actor will come up to them and ask them for help. And if they're feeling gratitude, they're more willing to help this person. Other times when
对这个任务的完成感到非常感激，5%的人确信是他们自己修好的。但他们确实非常、非常、非常感激。这就是我们实时诱导感恩的方式。所以当你以这种方式诱导感恩时，大卫，你是否看到它改变了人们对未来的思考方式？是的，所以当我们使用这种范式时——我们使用过好几次——它使人们更愿意“向前传递”，也就是说，它使他们更愿意在离开实验室后，突然有人——另一个演员——走过来向他们寻求帮助。如果他们感到感恩，他们更愿意帮助这个人。其他时候，当
they're engaged in financial decisions with other people, they'll make decisions that are a little costly to them, but benefit those around them. So they're more willing to share profits than take profits selfishly. And all of these kind of bring us back to the point I want to make, which is we're seeing people are willing to sacrifice in the moment to help other people to give them more money to do things that don't benefit them in the moment, but that we know from every evolutionary model out there brings gains down the line. And so by willing to sacrifice now, right, what you're doing is making sure that when you need help in the future, there are going to be people who will pay you back. And by cementing those
他们与其他人进行财务决策时，他们会做出对自己有一点代价，但对周围人有益的决定。所以他们更愿意分享利润，而不是自私地获取利润。所有这些都让我们回到了我想表达的观点，即我们看到人们愿意在当下做出牺牲来帮助他人，给他们更多的钱，做那些在当下对自己没有好处，但我们从每一个进化模型中都知道，这会带来长期的收益。所以通过愿意在现在做出牺牲，你所做的是确保当你未来需要帮助时，会有愿意回报你的人。通过巩固这些
relationships, you're going to have a lot of aggregated gains over time, even though in the moment, it's kind of costly to you. And all of us have felt in some ways in real life what people, you know, experienced in the experiment, someone goes out of their way to help us and you feel this sudden rush of gratitude. It almost feels like something physical. You once had the experience of a colleague going above and beyond when your family was expecting a child. Tell me what she did and what happened, David. Yeah, we had just been at my new job in Northeastern for a year or two and we were expecting our first daughter.
关系，你将随着时间的推移获得大量的累积收益，即使在当下，这对你来说是有代价的。我们所有人在现实生活中都以某种方式感受过人们在实验中经历的事情，有人不遗余力地帮助你，你会感到一阵突然的感恩之情。它几乎感觉像是某种生理反应。你曾经有过一位同事在你的家庭期待孩子时超越自我帮助你的经历。大卫，告诉我们她做了什么，发生了什么。是的，我们在东北大学的新工作岗位上才待了一两年，我们正在期待我们的第一个女儿。
And we went to this, what we thought was kind of just an end of the year celebration. It turned out that it was a surprise, a baby shower for us, which was just heartwarming. And one of my colleagues gave to my wife and I this beautiful baby quilt that she had hand made. And in that moment, I had the exact experience that you're saying, Shankar, I just felt this welling up of emotion. Sometimes we get gifts and we're like, oh great, now I have to give you something.
我们去参加了这个我们以为只是年终庆祝活动的聚会。结果这是一个惊喜，一个为我们准备的婴儿派对，这真是令人暖心。我的一位同事送给我妻子和我这床美丽的婴儿被子，是她亲手制作的。在那一刻，我有了你所说的完全相同的体验，尚卡尔，我只是感到这种情绪涌上心头。有时我们收到礼物，我们会想，“哦，太好了，现在我得给你回礼了。”
This wasn't that, right? This was like, oh my goodness. And in that moment, my heart just felt like it was warming and swelling. And what it did is it made me feel really valued by this person so much so that it made me think of our relationship in a whole different way. It made me feel in somebody's bondage to her and to want to go move forward and do things for her.
这不是那种感觉，对吧？这就像，“哦，天哪。”在那一刻，我的心感觉就像在变暖和膨胀。它让我感到被这个人深深地重视，以至于它让我以一种完全不同的方式思考我们的关系。它让我感到对她有一种羁绊，想要继续前进并为她做些事情。
And that's the beauty of gratitude, right? It is the sense that someone went out of their way to do something that was costly to them. Not always financially, it could be time, it could be, you know, just care. But it's a mark that they value you. And that's what cements relationships and makes you want to pay it back. And suddenly you're in this upward spiral of building relationships. I want to just dwell for a second at the point that you just made, David, which is it's not always the most expensive thing that generates gratitude. If your colleague had gone out and bought you something, what, $700, that would have been an extravagant gift. But in some ways, it was the personal effort that she put into the quail, to making the quail that communicated to you. This person is someone who really
这就是感恩的美妙之处，对吧？这是一种感觉，有人不遗余力地做了一些对他们来说有代价的事情。不一定是经济上的，可能是时间，可能只是关心。但这是一种标志，表明他们重视你。这就是巩固关系并让你想要回报的原因。突然之间，你进入了建立关系的良性循环。我想在大卫你刚才提到的那一点上停留一秒钟，即并非总是最昂贵的东西才会产生感恩。如果你的同事出去给你买了什么，比如700美元的东西，那将是一份奢侈的礼物。但在某种程度上，是她投入到被子里的个人努力，制作被子的过程，向你传达了：这个人是一个真正
cares about me. I'm truly grateful. And I feel like in some ways reciprocating or spreading this to other people. That's right. And if you think about it, right, you know, the argument that I always make is self-control didn't evolve so that we could save for retirement in good, good grades, self-control evolve so that we would have a good character, that we would be fair, that we would cooperate, that other people would want to work with us. And sure, now we can pivot it so that instead of sacrificing to help someone else, I can
关心我的人。我真的很感激。我觉得在某种程度上，我想回报或将这种感觉传播给其他人。没错。如果你仔细想想，我总是提出的论点是，自控力进化并不是为了让我们能为退休储蓄和获得好成绩，自控力进化是为了让我们拥有良好的品格，让我们公平，让我们合作，让其他人愿意与我们共事。当然，现在我们可以转变它，这样我就不是牺牲自己去帮助别人，而是
sacrifice to help my own future self. But the origin is really one of morality. And that's why we look at emotions like gratitude and compassion as, as, as virtues. Shankar, if you gave me $10 right now, I didn't pay you back. I'd be ahead. But if I don't pay you back, or if you help me move my furniture and you need help moving yours, if I don't come and sacrifice to pay you back, that relationship is now going to end.
牺牲自己去帮助我未来的自己。但起源确实是道德层面的。这就是为什么我们将感恩和同情这样的情绪视为美德。尚卡尔，如果你现在给我10美元，我没有还你。我会占便宜。但如果我不还你，或者如果你帮我搬家具，而你需要帮助搬你的家具时，如果我不来牺牲自己来回报你，那段关系现在就会结束。
And I'll lose all of those gains going forward. And so it is a sacrifice in the moment for future benefit. I'm wondering when when you receive this wonderful hot warming gift from your colleague, whether you made a direct connection to the research that you were doing, was this in some ways like an aha moment for you? Yeah. In psychology, there's been a lot of work on ordinary emotions things like fear and anger but not on these more socially-oriented ones and because of that experience and how powerful it was it it was just another push
我将失去未来所有的收益。所以这是一种为了未来利益而在当下做出的牺牲。我想知道，当你从同事那里收到这份美妙的暖心礼物时，你是否直接联系到了你正在做的研究，这在某种程度上对你来说是一个“顿悟时刻”吗？是的。在心理学中，有很多关于恐惧和愤怒等普通情绪的研究，但没有关于这些更具社会导向的情绪的研究。因为那次经历以及它是多么强大，它只是又一次推动
for me to say you know there's something important here that we need to investigate. You cited study by Robert Emmons on the role that expressing gratitude has on stress. Do you remember what he did and what he found? I do. This was a great study because it was an experiment that was actually done in the field, so to speak. Emmons would ask a certain percentage of his subjects to engage in daily gratitude reflection, so he was making them basically count their blessings as an kind of an experimental intervention. And what he found is that over time, the individuals who did this reported that they were better able to engage in
我，让我说，“你知道，这里有一些重要的事情我们需要调查。”你引用了罗伯特·埃蒙斯关于表达感恩对压力影响的研究。你记得他做了什么以及他发现了什么吗？我记得。这是一项很棒的研究，因为它实际上是在实地进行的实验。埃蒙斯会要求一定比例的受试者进行日常感恩反思，所以他基本上是让他们数算自己的祝福，作为一种实验干预。他发现，随着时间的推移，这样做的人报告说他们能更好地进行
exercise, again, a type of sacrifice in the moment for future gain. They reported better quality of their relationships. They reported less symptoms of illness. And so taking together what this kind of signifies is to me that it's practicing gratitude is enhancing people's well-being and kind of reducing the stress that comes from illness or feelings of loneliness or disconnection. You also started studying by Wendy Mendes, I believe, at the University of California at San Francisco, looking at the relationship between gratitude and stress, or at least how gratitude can buffer the effective stress.
锻炼——同样，这是一种为了未来收益而在当下做出的牺牲。他们报告了更好的关系质量。他们报告了更少的疾病症状。所以综合起来，这对我来说意味着练习感恩正在增强人们的幸福感，并减少因疾病或孤独感或脱节感而产生的压力。你还开始研究加州大学旧金山分校的温迪·门德斯的研究，观察感恩与压力之间的关系，或者至少感恩如何缓冲压力的影响。
Yeah. So Wendy did this really interesting study where she used a technique called the Trier or Social Stress Measure, which is used in psychology online. Think about it like this. Pretend you're going for a job interview and you're going to stand up in front of three people and kind of give a little speech. The people are instructed to be very stone faced to give no feedback.
是的。所以温迪做了这个非常有趣的研究，她使用了一种叫做“特里尔社会压力测量”的技术，这在心理学中是在线的。试着这样想。假装你要去面试，你要站在三个人面前做一个简短的演讲。这些人被指示要面无表情，不给予任何反馈。
And you can imagine as you're doing this and you see no smiles, it's not a very rewarding experience that it causes a spiral of stress and that's been shown many times. What Wendy found was that individuals who are regularly more grateful in their life, individuals who practice more gratitude.
你可以想象，当你这样做时，你看到没有笑容，这不是一个非常有回报的经历，它会导致压力的螺旋上升，这已经被多次证明了。温迪发现，生活中经常更感恩的人，那些练习更多感恩的人，
And in some ways what what that basically is, is it's an intervention, right? People who are daily thinking about feeling grateful, cultivating it in their lives. She found it was basically like a booster shot for stress reduction. What's remarkable here is that the effect seems almost effortless, right?
在某种程度上，这基本上是一种干预，对吧？每天都在思考感到感恩、在生活中培养它的人。她发现这基本上就像是减压的加强针。这里引人注目的是，这种效果似乎几乎是不费吹灰之力的，对吧？
So if I induce gratitude on myself, it's almost like I've made the task easier. It's not like I'm actually working harder to accomplish the task. That's right, it's not building yourself controlled by giving you more willpower. It's basically working from the bottom up by changing what you value.
所以如果我诱导自己产生感恩，就好像我让任务变得更容易了。这不像是我为了完成任务而真的在更努力地工作。没错，它不是通过给你更多的意志力来建立你的自控力。它基本上是从底层向上工作，通过改变你的价值观。
And if you value something more than you normally would, if you value a future reward, your future health, your future savings, doing the right thing for your friends more than you normally would, if you value a future reward, your future health, your future savings, doing the right thing for your friends more than you normally would, then it just becomes easier to persevere toward it. Now, there's a lot of work these days on habits, right? Build a habit so that you can achieve your goals, study more, build a habit to save. And that's true, but the problem with most habits is they're focused on one narrow outcome. If I build a habit to study more, it's not going to help me save money.
如果你比平时更看重某样东西，比如你更看重未来的回报、未来的健康、未来的储蓄，或者更看重为朋友做正确的事，那么坚持朝着这些目标努力就会变得更容易。如今，关于习惯的研究有很多，对吧？养成习惯以实现目标，多学习，养成储蓄的习惯。这确实没错，但大多数习惯的问题在于它们只关注一个狭窄的结果。如果我养成多学习的习惯，它并不能帮我省钱。
But if you build a habit to cultivate gratitude, it's going to play out in many different domains, domains of exercise, domains of health, domains of dieting, domains of saving money, domains of studying, any time that it requires you to value the future more than the present. You say that many Americans miss the point when it comes to a festival like Thanksgiving David. Most people think it's merely a chance to express gratitude for close friends and family. Keeping in mind what you just told me that in some ways gratitude has the superpower, if you will, to affect many dimensions of your life. What are we getting wrong when we think about Thanksgiving merely as a location to look
但如果你养成培养感恩之心的习惯，它会在许多不同的领域发挥作用，比如锻炼、健康、饮食、储蓄、学习，任何需要你比现在更看重未来的时刻。大卫，你说很多美国人在感恩节这样的节日里抓不住重点。大多数人认为这仅仅是一个向亲朋好友表达感激的机会。考虑到你刚才告诉我的，感恩在某种程度上有一种“超能力”，可以影响你生活的许多方面。当我们仅仅把感恩节看作一个回顾过去、仅仅看作一个认可身边最亲近之人的场合时，我们到底错在哪里？
back and merely as a location to recognize those closest to us? Yeah, people get angry at me when I say this, they don't get angry, Shankur, but I often say, thanks, gratitude is wasted on Thanksgiving. It's not that it's a bad thing, but what I mean is really the benefits of gratitude are important on all the other days of the year when we need to delay our gratification to gain our future goals. And so, yes, it's important on Thanksgiving, but what you want to do is cultivate it more regularly on the other days, because by doing that, you'll ensure that when Thanksgiving
是的，当我这么说时，人们会对我生气，也不是生气，尚卡尔，但我经常说，感恩节浪费了感恩。并不是说感恩节不好，我的意思是，感恩的益处在一年中的其他日子里更为重要，因为我们需要推迟满足感以实现未来的目标。所以，是的，感恩节很重要，但你想要做的是在其他日子里更经常地培养这种心态，因为这样做，你就能确保当明年的感恩节到来时，你会有更多值得感恩的事情。很多年前，当你还是个孩子的时候，你和父亲有过冲突，这当然和世界上历史上每一个孩子都一样。但请告诉我你和他之间的冲突，以及你最近是如何看待那场冲突的。
comes next year, you will have more to be grateful for. Many years ago, when you were a kid, you had the experience of having conflicts with your dad, which is of course exactly like every other child in the history of the world. But tell me about the conflict that you had with him and how you've come to think about that conflict in more recent times. how you've come to think about that conflict in more recent times. Yeah, so when I was an early teen, my dad decided that every summer,
你最近是如何看待那场冲突的。是的，当我还是个十几岁的少年时，我父亲决定每年夏天，
I should engage in some type of academic activity. And, you know, I had just finished a year of school and I did not want to go and do an academic activity to the summer. I wanted to have fun play sports with my friends or do anything. And so, you know, he would put me in a computer camp or something like this. And it would cause strife because, you know, I would get annoyed. Like, Dad, why do I have to do this? But later on, I realized that he's doing this was his way of trying to ensure that more doors would be open to me in the future. My family, I came from a background that was very humble in terms of educational background
我都应该参加某种学术活动。你知道，我刚结束一年的学业，我不想在夏天去参加什么学术活动。我想玩得开心，和朋友们做运动，或者做任何事。所以，你知道，他会把我送进电脑夏令营之类的活动。这会引起冲突，因为，你知道，我会感到恼火。比如，爸爸，我为什么要这样做？但后来我意识到，他这样做是他确保我未来有更多机会的一种方式。我的家庭背景非常卑微，无论是教育背景
and in terms of economic backgrounds. I'm a first generation college student. And he felt so strongly about this, that he was willing to put up with my veteran about it and not wanting to do it. But more than that, I also found out that because we were from such humble financial backgrounds, he went to other members of our family
还是经济背景。我是第一代大学生。他对此非常坚持，甚至愿意忍受我对此的抱怨和不情愿。但不仅如此，我还发现，因为我们经济背景非常卑微，他甚至去向我们家族的其他成员
and asked for help for money so that he could provide me with these opportunities. And so I wasn't grateful for it at the time, but when looking back on it, when I learned about this and I saw it as a parent myself, I became incredibly grateful. The Buddhist talk about the difference between true compassion and idiot compassion. An idiot compassion is doing something that allows somebody to feel good in the moment and happy in the moment even though it's not good for their future outcomes.
寻求金钱帮助，以便为我提供这些机会。所以当时我并不感激，但回过头来看，当我了解到这一点，并且自己也为人父母时，我变得无比感激。佛教谈论真慈悲与愚痴慈悲的区别。愚痴慈悲是指做一些让某人在当下感到舒服和快乐的事情，即使这对他们的未来结果并不好。
Wise compassion is helping them to do things that are hard in the moment even as they don't want to do it. And because my dad had that wise compassion at the time, and was willing to put up with my arguing, it led to something that I'm much more grateful for in the future. It's a little sad though, isn't it, which is that if we, if we could remind ourselves to be more grateful to people in the moment even when it seems as if they are working at cross purposes with us, presumably eight would help us see the value of what it is they are telling us which is a good thing in and of itself and second it probably would bind us to them more closely than it would otherwise.
智慧慈悲是帮助他们做那些在当下很困难、即使他们不想做的事情。因为我父亲当时拥有那种智慧慈悲，并且愿意忍受我的争吵，这导致了后来我更加感激的结果。但这有点令人难过，不是吗？如果我们能在当下提醒自己对他人更加感恩，即使看起来他们似乎在与我们作对，想必这不仅能帮助我们看到他们所说之事的价值，这本身就是一件好事，而且其次，它可能会让我们与他们的联系比原本更紧密。
Both of those are true and that's why I think there's not an emphasis on gratitude, I think, anymore in terms of when kids are growing up, as much as there used to be traditionally. And I think, to the extent that we encourage people, young or old, to think more about what other people are doing for them and how what their intent is and to see opportunities for gratitude. The more we look for those opportunities to feel it,
这两点都是真的，这就是为什么我认为现在在孩子成长过程中，对感恩的强调不如传统上那么多了。我认为，在某种程度上，如果我们鼓励人们，无论老少，多去思考别人为他们做了什么，他们的意图是什么，并去寻找感恩的机会。我们越是寻找那些去感受感恩的机会，
the more we're increasing the opportunity to cultivate it in our own lives. Did you have a chance to thank your dad, David? I did. I did later on. I wish that I had been more aware at the time, but you know, such as the wisdom of age, right? you know, such as the wisdom of age, right? When we come back, is feeling grateful just something you feel, or is it something you can learn to do?
我们就越是在增加在自己生活中培养这种心态的机会。大卫，你有机会感谢你的父亲吗？我有。我后来感谢了他。我真希望当时我能更有意识，但你知道，这就是岁月的智慧，对吧？你知道，这就是岁月的智慧，对吧？当我们回来时，感恩仅仅是一种感觉，还是你可以学会去做的事情？
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Our emotions are extremely powerful. There are times when they can lead us astray and cause us to undermine our own long-term goals. But just because some emotions cause us to become short-sighted, that doesn't mean all emotions cause us to be impetuous. Some emotions in fact seem to help us focus on our long-term interests. They can help us exercise more, eat healthier, and save more wisely.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们的情绪极其强大。有时它们会把我们引入歧途，导致我们破坏自己的长期目标。但仅仅因为某些情绪让我们变得目光短浅，并不意味着所有情绪都会让我们变得冲动。事实上，有些情绪似乎能帮助我们专注于长期利益。它们可以帮助我们多锻炼、吃得更健康、更明智地储蓄。
David, a lot of your work is published in modern, pure-reviewed psychology journals, but the ideas you're talking about feel really ancient to me. Many cultural and spiritual traditions around the world celebrate the idea of pausing to give thanks. You mentioned in our earlier conversation just the idea of counting your blessings. It seems to me that many of those traditions are arriving at the same underlying idea as the psychological studies, right? That's right.
大卫，你的许多研究都发表在现代同行评审的心理学期刊上，但你谈论的这些观点对我来说感觉非常古老。世界各地的许多文化和精神传统都推崇停下来表达感谢的理念。你在我们之前的谈话中提到了“数算你的祝福”这个想法。在我看来，许多这些传统得出的基本理念与心理学研究是一样的，对吧？没错。
It's funny you should mention that. I'm working on my next book, which is called How God Works, and it is basically looking at ancient practices and rituals and advice from religions and kind of evaluating them in a scientific framework. and what I found time and time again is that some of these ancient practices like prayers for giving thanks, even families saying grace regularly before they dinner and giving thanks. Those are ways they're presented theologically, but what they actually are are kind of beautiful nudges to the mind. And what we see is that even maybe your religious leaders didn't understand the science of why these things worked, they could see the outcomes. And I think there's a lot of evidence for that. What we're finding time and again is that being grateful, engaging in compassion, these lead to long-term benefits for people in terms of their physical and mental well-being.
你提到这一点很有趣。我正在写我的下一本书，书名叫《上帝如何运作》，它基本上是在审视古老的习俗、仪式和宗教建议，并以科学的框架来评估它们。我一次又一次发现，其中一些古老的习俗，比如感恩的祈祷，甚至家庭在晚餐前定期做餐前祷告并表达感谢。这些在神学上是这样呈现的，但它们实际上是心灵的美好暗示。我们看到的是，即使你的宗教领袖可能不理解这些事情为何有效的科学原理，他们也能看到结果。我认为有很多证据支持这一点。我们一次又一次地发现，心怀感恩、参与慈悲行为，这些都会给人们的身心健康带来长期益处。
You've been particularly interested in a group of people who appear to have superpowers when it comes to delaying gratification. They can go long periods without food and water, they're adapted placing the interest of others before themselves. Tell me about the connection you saw between your psychological research and Buddhist monks. Yeah, so when we first started studying self-control and what role emotions play in it. I also had another group of students who were studying mindfulness meditation. And I thought, well, who knows more about delaying gratification and cravings and not being attached to these things
你一直对一群在推迟满足感方面似乎拥有“超能力”的人特别感兴趣。他们可以长时间不吃不喝，他们适应将他人的利益置于自己之上。请告诉我你在你的心理学研究和佛教僧侣之间看到的联系。是的，当我们刚开始研究自控力以及情绪在其中扮演的角色时。我还有另一组学生在研究正念冥想。我想，谁比佛教僧侣更了解推迟满足感、克制欲望以及不执着于这些事物呢？
in Buddhist monks? So I spent some time talking to the Buddhist monks. And one high ranking one told me that he said, you know, when monks first take their vows to be chased and to not drink alcohol, et cetera, and to not gamble, he said, you know, when monks first take their vows to be chased and to not drink alcohol, etc. It's not gamble. He said, they fail just like everybody else. But what he said is over time through meditation, what happens is it begins to unleash these feelings of compassion. And he has once that compassion starts to be unleashed, resisting temptation becomes much easier. And it's similar to the idea that I was talking
所以我花了一些时间与佛教僧侣交谈。一位高僧告诉我，他说，你知道，当僧侣们第一次发誓要守贞、不喝酒等等，并且不赌博时，他说，你知道，当僧侣们第一次发誓要守贞、不喝酒等等，并且不赌博时。他说，他们和其他人一样会失败。但他所说的是，随着时间的推移，通过冥想，发生的事情是它开始释放出慈悲的感觉。他说，一旦那种慈悲开始被释放，抵制诱惑就变得容易多了。这和我刚才谈到的关于感恩的想法很相似。
about with gratitude. When you feel those emotions, they change what your mind values. It makes you value the long-term more. And what you find is that just makes it easier to persevere toward your goals and to control selfish temptations. Now, it's one thing to say that this is true for people who have practiced very difficult, you know, meditation techniques for years on end. But I understand that you have studied whether novices, people who know very little or nothing about meditation, can learn these practices. Can you tell me about the study you conducted along these lines in Boston? Yeah, so we believe that, you know, after a few weeks we might be able to see some changes. And so we invited people who had never meditated before from the Boston community to come to
当你感受到那些情绪时，它们会改变你大脑的价值观。它让你更看重长期利益。你会发现，这让你更容易坚持实现目标，并控制自私的诱惑。现在，说这对那些多年来练习过非常困难的冥想技术的人来说是真的，是一回事。但我了解到，你研究过初学者，即那些对冥想知之甚少或一无所知的人，是否也能学会这些练习。你能告诉我你在波士顿进行的这方面的研究吗？是的，我们相信，几周后我们或许能看到一些变化。所以我们邀请了波士顿社区从未冥想过的人来到
our lab, and we collaborated with the Buddhist Lama who was going to teach them meditative techniques. So half of them came to the lab for eight weeks of meditation, and then she created MP3s that they could take homes for their galley practice and they had another bunch of people who were put on the waiting list so they received no training at all. After that was done, we told them come back to the lab after these eight weeks we want to measure how meditation affected your memory and your ability to engage in certain types of cognitive activities which seems kind of straightforward. There's a lot of work on how meditation affects memory.
我们的实验室，我们与一位将教他们冥想技巧的佛教喇嘛合作。他们中有一半人来到实验室进行了八周的冥想，然后她制作了MP3，让他们带回家进行日常练习，还有另一群人被列入候补名单，所以他们根本没有接受任何训练。结束后，我们告诉他们八周后回到实验室，我们想测量冥想如何影响你的记忆力和你参与某些类型认知活动的能力，这看起来似乎很直接。关于冥想如何影响记忆力，已经有很多研究了。
But the real experiment took place in the waiting room. So when they came to our lab, there was a waiting room of three chairs and two people were already sitting in the chairs. These were Confederates or actors who worked for us. And then came in the subjects, what did they do? Well, they sat in the third chair waiting to be called. About two minutes later, we had another actor come down the hall and enter the waiting room.
但真正的实验发生在候诊室。当他们来到我们的实验室时，有一个放着三把椅子的候诊室，已经有两个人坐在椅子上了。这些人是我们的同伙或演员。然后受试者进来了，他们做了什么？嗯，他们坐在第三把椅子上等着被叫到。大约两分钟后，我们让另一位演员走过走廊进入候诊室。
She didn't really have a broken foot, but she was on crutches wearing one of those boots that you wear when your foot is broken, wincing in pain. And she came into the room and there were no chairs left for her. And so she basically just kind of winced and let out a little painful sigh of discomfort it leaned against the law and our two other actors were told to ignore her And so the question was what would the subject do would he or she be willing to sacrifice his or her immediate comfort
她的脚并没有真的骨折，但她拄着拐杖，穿着那种脚骨折时穿的靴子，痛苦地皱着眉头。她走进房间，已经没有椅子给她坐了。所以她基本上只是皱了皱眉，发出一声痛苦的叹息，靠在墙上，而我们的另外两名演员被告知要无视她。所以问题是受试者会怎么做？他或她是否愿意牺牲自己当下的舒适，
By getting up seeing if you could help this person offering his feet to her or he would he ignore her like everybody else did and what we found Or would he ignore her like everybody else did? And what we found was in the conditions among the non-meditators, about 16% of people did this, they got up and offered their seat and see if they could help this person. But among the meditators, it jumped to 50%. Would immediately get up and offer their seat to this person's seat if they could give her anything.
站起来看看能否帮助这个人，把座位让给她，还是他会像其他人一样无视她？我们发现，或者他会无视她吗？我们发现，在非冥想者的条件下，大约16%的人这样做了，他们站起来让座，看看能否帮助这个人。但在冥想者中，这个比例跃升至50%。他们会立即站起来，把座位让给这个人，看看能否给她任何帮助。
And we've replicated this finding, so it's not just kind of a one-off thing. So one thing this experiment suggests to me is that it might be better to think of gratitude as a skill rather than as a trait, or just simply an emotion, something that just pops up, unbidden in our hearts.
我们已经重复了这个发现，所以这不仅仅是一个偶然事件。所以这个实验向我暗示的一件事是，把感恩看作一种技能，而不是一种特质，或者仅仅是一种在心中不请自来的情绪，可能更好。
That's right. We have this idea of emotional intelligence that's been kind of percolating for the past decade or more in US hearts. That's right. You know, we have this idea of emotional intelligence has been kind of percolating for the past decade or more in US culture. And there are several parts to it. One is, can you read another person's emotion to know what they're feeling? One is, can you kind of keep calm so you're not disruptive. The schools often use this when they're worried about this about keeping little Johnny Kwaia in class. He's not a disruption. But there's a third part that people forget about. And that third part of emotional intelligence
没错。我们有这种“情商”的概念，在过去十年或更长时间里，它一直在美国文化中渗透。没错。你知道，我们有这种“情商”的概念，在过去十年或更长时间里，它一直在美国文化中渗透。它有几个部分。一是，你能读懂别人的情绪以了解他们的感受吗？二是，你能保持冷静，不造成破坏吗？学校在担心保持课堂纪律时经常使用这一点，比如让小约翰尼安静地待在教室里，不造成干扰。但人们忘记了第三部分。而情商的第三部分
is learning how to use your emotions as tools or as skills to achieve your goals. And that's exactly what we're talking about, right? Emotions are tools that you can cultivate in your life. When you meditate, you're building an automatic response to feel compassion more regularly. When you count your blessings daily, you're engaging in an activity, you're curating your own emotional states, you're making yourself
是学习如何利用你的情绪作为工具或技能来实现你的目标。这正是我们所谈论的，对吧？情绪是你可以在生活中培养的工具。当你冥想时，你正在建立一种更经常感受慈悲的自动反应。当你每天数算你的祝福时，你正在参与一项活动，你正在策划自己的情绪状态，你正在让自己
feel more grateful. There are periodically stories that you see on local television, David, that are along the lines of this one. Take a listen. Boris Logan Norris was working the Starbucks window at 9 a.m. when a customer offered to buy coffee for the strangers in the car behind him. It started out by someone just came up and they wanted to do exactly that and just pay it forward and it just kept going. So how many cars participated? Well that was just about 30 more that went through. I know we're at least up to 160. Talk about this idea David. You've mentioned it briefly in the past. The idea that emotions such as gratitude are fundamentally contagious. That as you see them, you have a strong impulse
感到更感恩。大卫，你在当地电视上偶尔会看到这样的故事，比如这个。听听看。鲍里斯·洛根·诺里斯在上午9点在星巴克窗口工作时，一位顾客主动提出为他身后车里的陌生人买咖啡。这始于有人过来，他们想做完全一样的事情，只是传递这份善意，然后它就一直持续下去。那么有多少辆车参与了？嗯，大约又有30辆车通过了。我知道我们至少达到了160辆。大卫，谈谈这个想法。你过去曾简要提到过它。这种认为感恩等情绪从根本上具有传染性的想法。当你看到它们时，你有一种强烈的冲动
to be part of this, as you call it, this virtuous cycle. Yeah, I mean, that's one of the... So all emotions are catchy. You know, we're more likely to feel them. If I'm sitting next to someone who's anxious, that anxiety can rub off on me. But gratitude has kind of this added element. That is, it makes you want to pay it forward. And we found that in our own experiments when people leave the lab and a stranger comes up to them, they are more willing to help them.
去参与其中，正如你所说的，这个“良性循环”。是的，我的意思是，这是其中之一……所以所有的情绪都是会传染的。你知道，我们更有可能感受到它们。如果我坐在一个焦虑的人旁边，那种焦虑可能会传染给我。但感恩有一种额外的元素。也就是说，它让你想要传递这份善意。我们在自己的实验中发现，当人们离开实验室，有陌生人走近他们时，他们更愿意帮助他们。
And you see a time and again, like this, a toll booth or a Starbucks, people do this. And it drives economists crazy because they're a truly self-interested standpoint. Hey, that guy just bought me something. I'm the head, right? Why aren't I just taking my extra benefit and running? It's because it's built into us, right?
你一次又一次地看到这种情况，比如在收费站或星巴克，人们这样做。这让经济学家们抓狂，因为从纯粹的自利角度来看，嘿，那个人刚给我买了东西。我赚到了，对吧？为什么我不直接拿着我的额外好处跑掉呢？这是因为它是我们与生俱来的，对吧？
This idea that if we cooperate with one another, we get gains down the line. If we pay it forward, those gains come back to us. And all the evolutionary models, that is true. Gratitude is a device to make us willing to do that. So there's wonderful work by psychologist Elizabeth Dunn and Michael Norton that show giving is perceived in the brain as pleasure. But when we have gratitude, it even amps that up even more.
这种想法是，如果我们彼此合作，我们就会获得长远的收益。如果我们传递这份善意，这些收益就会回到我们身上。在所有的进化模型中，这是真的。感恩是一种让我们愿意这样做的机制。所以心理学家伊丽莎白·邓恩和迈克尔·诺顿有很棒的研究表明，给予在大脑中被感知为快乐。但当我们有感恩之心时，它甚至会进一步放大这种快乐。
It makes it even more pleasurable. It makes us more willing to do it. And it builds these cycles of cooperation in amazing ways and ways that don't seem to make a logical sense, but feel really rewarding. So there are going to be people who listen to this and say, look, this is all just pie in the sky. The people who really get ahead in life are the people who are brash and rude and have sharp elbows, gratitude and compassion are for suckers. What do you say to them, David?
它让它变得更加令人愉悦。它让我们更愿意去做。它以惊人的方式建立了这些合作循环，这些方式看起来并不符合逻辑，但感觉非常值得。所以肯定会有听众听到这里说，看，这全是空谈。在生活中真正取得成功的人是那些鲁莽、粗鲁、咄咄逼人的人，感恩和慈悲是给傻瓜准备的。大卫，你对他们说什么？
I get this question a lot. People say to me, David, I wanna be a success. Should I be a jerk or should it be a nice guy? And I say, well, what's your time frame? If you're a jerk in the short term, if you're selfish, if you don't help other people, you can get ahead. But in the long term, those individuals pay a price because people do not want to interact with them,
我经常被问到这个问题。人们对我说，大卫，我想成功。我应该做一个混蛋还是做一个好人？我说，好吧，你的时间框架是什么？如果你在短期内做一个混蛋，如果你自私，如果你不帮助别人，你可以领先。但从长远来看，这些人会付出代价，因为人们不想与他们互动、
partner with them, work with them. But I do worry about this because, you know, in some senses, am I making people, even in the moment, suckers? But we recently ran a study where we kind of tackled this question. And the way it worked was simply people were made to feel grateful by counting their blessings or not, and we normally do that.
与他们合作、与他们共事。但我确实对此感到担忧，因为，你知道，在某种意义上，我是否在当下让人们看起来像傻瓜？但我们最近进行了一项研究，我们以某种方式解决了这个问题。它的运作方式很简单，人们通过数算他们的祝福或不这样做来感受感恩，我们通常这样做。
And we had them watch Person A, Cheat Person B on something where Person A and Person B were both Confederates. And they had the opportunity to intervene. And what we found is people who were feeling grateful were more likely to intervene and try and correct person A's behavior, the person who cheated, even to engage in something we call third party punishment. That is they'd even pay a little money to have this person told, hey, you shouldn't do that to harm this other individual. And what we take from that is when you're feeling grateful, it doesn't make you a sucker, it doesn't make you willing to be walked all over. It makes you want to do the virtuous thing,
我们让他们观看A欺骗B，其中A和B都是同伙。他们有机会干预。我们发现，感到感恩的人更有可能干预并试图纠正A的行为，即那个欺骗的人，甚至参与我们所谓的“第三方惩罚”。也就是说，他们甚至会付一点钱让这个人被告知，嘿，你不应该那样伤害另一个人。我们从中得出的是，当你感到感恩时，它不会让你成为傻瓜，它不会让你愿意被随意践踏。它让你想要做正确的事，
but it also makes you willing to stand up for justice when you see someone else not being treated as well. And so the people who are feeling grateful, yes, they're impulses to do the right thing, but when they see injustices in the world, they're also the ones who are going to be more likely to call it out. You know, some years ago at Hidden Brain David, we began a weekly practice of acknowledging our unsung heroes on the show. So these were people who often walked in the background. And one thing I discovered is that once you start keeping an eye out for unsung heroes, they really are everywhere. Even the most trivial things need the help of so many different people. But here's the interesting part that I want to run by you. I've been surprised at how many
但它也让你愿意在看到别人没有得到公平对待时为正义挺身而出。所以那些感到感恩的人，是的，他们的冲动是做正确的事，但当他们看到世界上的不公时，他们也是更有可能指出来的人。你知道，几年前在《隐藏的大脑》，大卫，我们开始了一项每周在节目中表彰我们“无名英雄”的练习。所以这些人通常是在幕后默默付出的人。我发现的一件事是，一旦你开始留意无名英雄，他们真的无处不在。即使是最琐碎的事情也需要许多不同人的帮助。但这里有一个我想和你探讨的有趣部分。我很惊讶有多少
of our listeners tell us that they love the unsung hero segment of our show. Now, of course, much of the time, we are thanking people who my listeners don't know. What does it do you think about seeing someone else express gratitude, even if it is to a third party, someone you don't know, that makes us happy? I think two things. I think one in seeing someone else express gratitude, what it is, it's a good type of virtue signaling.
我们的听众告诉我们，他们喜欢我们节目中的“无名英雄”环节。当然，很多时候，我们感谢的是我的听众不认识的人。你认为看到别人表达感激，即使是对第三方，一个你不认识的人，会让我们感到快乐，这是为什么？我想有两点。我认为第一，看到别人表达感激，这是一种很好的“美德信号”。
It's an index that this person appreciates that they couldn't have achieved all their goals in the world on their own. And the argument you're making is similar to one my collaborator, the Connvis Bob Frank makes. We tend to have this assumption that everything good is due to our own efforts. And part of it is, but as you're saying, there are many unsung heroes. There are many people without whose help we wouldn't be where we are. And so expressing gratitude is a marker that this person appreciates that fact. And I think
这是一个指标，表明这个人意识到他们不可能独自实现世界上所有的目标。你提出的论点与我的合作者鲍勃·弗兰克提出的类似。我们往往有一种假设，认为所有好的事情都归功于我们自己的努力。部分确实如此，但正如你所说，有很多无名英雄。有许多人没有他们的帮助，我们就不会有今天。所以表达感激是一个标志，表明这个人意识到这一事实。我认为
it's a marker and a reminder that in some ways we're all in this together and we are going to be appreciative of that. You cite a sociologist who says that gratitude is the moral memory of humankind. I love that idea. That's really beautiful. Yeah, that's strange, Zimol. It is beautiful. I think what it is is, it reminds us that everything we've achieved is not solely through our own efforts.
这是一个标志，也是一个提醒，在某种程度上我们都在同一条船上，我们会对此心存感激。你引用了一位社会学家的话，他说感恩是人类的“道德记忆”。我喜欢这个想法。这真的很美。是的，这很奇怪，齐莫尔。这确实很美。我认为它提醒我们，我们所取得的一切并非完全通过我们自己的努力。
And it reminds us to pay it back and to pay it forward. And if we do that, the outcome for everybody is going to be a better one. I want you to tell me about a moment in your life that occurred sometime ago, David, when some of your elderly mothers, caregivers did something special for her. What did they do? And again, what effect did it have on you? Yeah, so my mom is 99 and living in her house, but she requires 24 or seven care. And so she has a group of caregivers for women who help her with her needs throughout the day.
它提醒我们要回报并传递这份善意。如果我们这样做，对每个人来说结果都会更好。我想让你告诉我你生命中发生过的一件事，大卫，那是前段时间，你年迈母亲的护理人员为她做了一些特别的事情。他们做了什么？再说一次，它对你有什么影响？是的，我妈妈99岁了，住在她自己的房子里，但她需要24小时全天候护理。所以她有一群护理人员，这些女性全天帮助她处理她的需求。
But what became clear to me is that on her birthday, when she turned 99, they organized a party for her. They made it so that the neighbors came, they bought her gifts. They made her her favorite meals and desserts. And this is so far above and beyond what they are required to do for their job as caretakers. I cost to themselves in terms of time and effort, money even, and it was just so heartwarming to me,
但让我清楚的是，在她99岁生日那天，她们为她组织了一个派对。她们让邻居们都来了，她们给她买了礼物。她们为她做了她最喜欢的饭菜和甜点。这远远超出了她们作为护理人员的工作要求。她们在时间和精力上付出了代价，甚至还有金钱，这对我来说太暖心了，
and I choke up, I choke up, I choke up, and I'm gonna tear up when I think about it because it made me feel so grateful because here's my mom I can't give her the kind of care she needs personally. I'm an only child. I live far away and These people yes, they're being paid to do it, but they go so far above and beyond that it just made me Seal more gratitude than I could ever have imagined and again It made me want to sacrifice and do wonderful things for them.
我哽咽了，我哽咽了，我哽咽了，想到它我就会热泪盈眶，因为它让我感到非常感激，因为这是我的妈妈，我无法亲自给她她所需要的照顾。我是独生子。我住得很远，而这些人，是的，她们是拿钱做这份工作，但她们做得远远超出了职责范围，这让我感受到的感激之情比我能想象的还要多，再一次，它让我想要牺牲自己，为她们做美妙的事情。
And so yes, it's heartwarming, yes, it's beautiful, but it also nudges us, right? And nudges our minds to either pay those people back or to pay it forward to others. And I think that's the beauty of gratitude. It ensures that there's gonna be more blessings to come. David Distanneau is a psychologist at Northeastern University. He is the author of emotional success, the power of gratitude, compassion, and pride.
所以是的，这很暖心，是的，这很美，但它也提醒我们，对吧？它提醒我们的心灵要么回报那些人，要么将这份善意传递给他人。我认为这就是感恩的美妙之处。它确保未来会有更多的祝福。大卫·德斯塔诺是东北大学的心理学家。他是《情感成功：感恩、慈悲和骄傲的力量》一书的作者。
David, thanks for joining me today on Hidden Bray. Thank you, Shankar. Music Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Midrall Media is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarell, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. A run-song hero this week is someone who has helped me think through numerous aspects of launching an independent production company.
大卫，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。音乐《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。Midrall Media是我们独家的广告销售合作伙伴。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·夸雷尔、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。本周的“无名英雄”是一位帮助我思考创办独立制作公司诸多方面的人。
Very often, the nuts and bolts of the organizations in which we work are hidden from view, but I can attest it's really important to get the fundamentals right. Over the past year or so, my friend and former colleague Lily Ladd helped me brainstorm how to launch a small business. Her strategic council has proven invaluable. It's shaping all the creative work we do on a weekly basis, which makes her a walking definition of an unsung
通常，我们工作组织的细节是隐藏在视线之外的，但我可以证明，把基础工作做好真的很重要。在过去的一年左右，我的朋友和前同事莉莉·拉德帮助我集思广益如何创办一家小企业。她的战略建议被证明是无价的。它正在塑造我们每周所做的所有创意工作，这使她成为“无名英雄”的活生生的定义。
hero. It helps that besides being a smart thinker, Lily is a terrific listener and a wonderful human being. Thank you, Lily. I'm truly grateful. For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook, Twitter, and at hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week.
除了是一位聪明的思想家之外，莉莉还是一位出色的倾听者和美好的人，这很有帮助。谢谢你，莉莉。我真的非常感激。想了解更多关于《隐藏的大脑》的信息，你可以在Facebook、Twitter和hiddenbrain.org上关注我们。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你 本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。